we've talked a lot about aggregate
demand over the last few videos and so
this video I thought I would talk a
little bit about aggregate supply and in
particular we're going to think about
aggregate supply in the long run and in
economics whether it's a micro or macro
economics when we think about long-run
we're thinking about enough time for a
lot of fixed costs and a lot of fixed
contracts to expire so in the short term
you might be stuck into some labor
contract or stuck into your using some
factory that you've already paid money
for so it was a fixed cost but over the
long run you'll have a chance that
factory will wear down and you'll have a
chance to decide whether you want
another factory or the price of the
factory might change or in the long run
you'll have a chance contracts will
expire and you'll have a chance to
renegotiate those contracts at a new
price and so that's what we really mean
when we talk about the long-run and so
I'm going to plot aggregate supply on
the same axis as we as we plotted
aggregate demand and we're going to
focus on the long-run now and then we're
gonna think about what actually might
happen in the short-run while we are in
fixed price contracts or we already have
spent money on something or we aree we
have already in some ways there are
sticky things that can't adjust as
quickly but will first focus on the
long-run so this axis I'm just going to
plot price and remember we're thinking
in macroeconomic terms this is the
prices this is some measure of the
prices of goods and services in our
economy and this axis right over here
the horizontal axis is going to be real
GDP and that once again this is just a
model you should take everything extract
everything in economics the huge grain
of salt
these are oversimplifications of a
highly highly complex theorem the
economy millions and millions of actors
doing complex things human beings each
of them in their brain have billions and
billions and billions of neurons doing
all sorts of unpredictable things but
economists like to make really
simplifying super simplifying
assumptions so that we can deal with in
an attractive way and even deal in a
mathematical way and so the assumption
that economists often make when we think
about aggregate supply and aggregate
demand is in the long-run real GDP
actually does not depend on prices in
the long-run so what you have is
regardless of what the price is you're
going to have the same real GDP and you
could kind of view this as a natural
natural level of productivity for the
economy so this is some level right
over here that's important to realize
this is just a snapshot in time and this
is all else things equal so we're not
assuming that we're having changes in
productivity over time or or this is
just a snapshot if we did have any of
those things that change so for example
if we had if the population increased
then that would cause this level to
shift to the right then we would have a
higher natural level of productivity if
for whatever reason we were able to
create tools so that it was easier to
find people jobs there's always a
natural rate of unemployment that you
know Peters frictions people have to
look for jobs some people have to
retrain to get their skills but maybe we
improve that in some way so that there's
some website where people can find jobs
easier or easier ways to train for jobs
and the natural level of unemployment
goes down more people can produce that
would also shift this curve to the right
you could have a reality where there's
technological improvements that would
also then all of a sudden on an average
people would become more productive that
could shift things to the right you
could have discovery of natural
resources new land that is super fertile
and everything else that could also
shift things to the right you could have
you could have a war and maybe your
factories get bombed or you know about
people you know bad things happen in a
war factory you know especially if the
war is on your soil and that could
actually shift things that could
actually shift things to the left so
it's important to realize that this is
just taking a snapshot in time and a lot
of these other things that we think
about would just shift it in one
direction or another so I'm going to
leave you there and you know this is a
kind of it might not seem intuitive at
first cuz you're saying wait look you
know if prices were to change
dramatically if all of a sudden
everything in the economy got twice as
expensive that would have some impact on
people's minds and that they would they
would but they would behave differently
and all the rest and that might affect
how much they can produce and and we did
think a little bit about that when we
thought about aggregate demand but when
we think about aggregate somaye this
supply we're just thinking about their
capability to produce and we're saying
all else equal we're saying that
people's mind shifts aren't changing the
willingness to work or isn't changing
nothing else is changing technology
isn't changing and given that price
really is just a numeric thing if you
just looked at the resources and the
product the productive capability of a
country the factors of production the
people and all the rest
regardless of what the prices are they
in theory should be able to produce the
same level of goods and services